okay thanks for coming to the last
session of the day and also of the
workshop and yells will tell us about
non interactive television so thank you
Hey so welcome hey thanks for organizing
this it's a wonderful a great way to be
here very exciting time I feel for
quantum crypto the marriage of quantum
crypto so what you'll see in what I'm
going to talk about today is actually
it's a it's a crypto result that uses
it's about verifying computation they're
fine deterministic computation but we're
gonna use kind of were inspired in using
ideas from quantum to get here so so
yeah it's based on a bunch of actually a
series of work starting with ran arising
on hot plume and then with Vika or
kelskiy and justin Holmgren and then a
very recent result a but what we're
going to show today is it's very similar
to to the talks we've seen before about
verify verifiable computation but we're
focused here in the non interactive
setting so let me explain a what what we
mean but before I go ahead I just want
to say a big thank you to Justin because
he gave me some of the slides so the
beautiful slides here are thanks to him
the ugly ones are my own okay so let's
start so what is the what is the
verifiable computation in the non
interactive setting so this is the
problem we're trying to solve there is a
very weak device not not only classical
he's really weak okay he can't run his
time he can run only in very short
amount of time there is a cloud here
that's powerful that's your prover okay
so there are powerful prove ER and this
provers gonna prove correctness of
computations to this with weak device
and what the way we're seeing about
everyone we want the proofs to be just
certificates we want them to be not
interactive and the way we get it is as
follows the weak device once and for all
sent some public parameters some strings
some short string to the cloud and now
for any computation so there's a true
machine m that you want to prove their
turing machine m an output and input x
outputs one
after time T okay so you want to prove
that the crowd can just give like a
certificate like remember the
mathematical proofs were used to that
you know you just write on a piece of
paper that's the kind of proof he's
gonna give to the weak verifier to the
smart watch here it's just gonna be but
short proof that the truth machine am an
input X outputs one within T time steps
okay and you can do that over and over
again so for another computation another
computation who chooses this computation
anybody can choose it the smart watch
can say please you know prove the
compute and prove it can the cloud
choose someone asking choose but the
point is that this week device can get
proofs for any computation and you can
verify them very efficiently okay that's
what we want to do and let me define it
a bit more formally by the way well I
see you guys I know you're a very
interactive audience so please feel free
to interrupt me at any time I I'm not
sure I'm gonna try to pace it I don't
quite know you know what you guys know
and don't know so please please stop me
you know with questions okay so what is
the goal what subject thank you yeah so
I'm thinking the result is just being a
bit but that's just for simplicity you
can think about is being a string but
yeah so he's gonna get this is my result
let's say 1 or 0 or a long string and
the proof that indeed this is the result
yes and you can think of them as being
deterministic Turing machine can be
non-deterministic actually can also be
quantum and we're going to get to them
the at the end of the talk our results
are not in the quantum setting but we're
gonna get to that setting in the end of
the talk ok so what is the goal what do
we want the first thing that makes this
non-trivial is we want efficiency ok
efficiency and sink sink nests so what
do I mean the communication complexity
should be very short the length of the
proof should be very short
how short depends and T only poly
logarithmically ok the runtime of the
bear the very should be very efficient
ok I still do the computation on its own
how efficient well
needs to read kind of the input which i
think of it is just like the length of X
because think of X as being greater than
log T and greater than the description
of this uniform Turing machine here but
essentially he needs the read to read
the input that he must do and then we're
allowing like poly log overhead okay but
essentially he cannot do the computation
of course and the prover should also be
efficient so the prover needs to do the
computation okay if he has a witness
okay he he needs to do the computation
but he should not he's not like a Merlin
like in a nun stock okay it's more he
second a realist top where we want him
to be as efficient as running the
computation plus some polynomial time
some polynomial overhead yes why does it
include so actually the communication
can include the length of X it will
still be very interesting the reason I'm
just writing this is because this is
what we achieve we can get better so I'm
yeah it depends only power growth weekly
ante the length of the proof and the
parameters will not depend on the length
of X so you think who generates this
right so so it can it depends on the
application you can think of application
anybody can choose it you can think of
application whether there's a weak
verifier so I or weak device me I'm weak
and I want to you strong wish to prove
things to me or to compute things from
me so I come and tell you oh so me as
though we device I tell you what
computations to do and you do it you can
think of settings that actually the
cloud you know chooses the computation
until the world earth tells what will
get back there is a point there but yeah
there's a delicate the answer is not as
simple but the answer is essentially yes
a we're thinking of it as sending ahead
of time once and for all and then you
can reuse it again and again and again
a there's a star there which I'll say a
little later what the star is yeah so I
want the prove it to be efficient but if
it's a non-deterministic computation of
course you can I mean if it's an NP
computation you can be efficient but you
can be efficient given the witness so I
want him to be as efficient at the
person if there's a witness and yeah
what I want to emphasize here which is
different from what we've seen today is
that this is even interesting for
polynomial time computations so this is
also what's called doubly efficient
proof systems where even for P so it
let's say all I wanted to delegate
polynomial time computations still miss
this verifier is not P he is
he wasn't very you know he doesn't want
to do the computation that's too much
for him he only wants to running this
time so actually for this talk I think
it'll be it's a you should think in your
head when you listen to the stock as
delegating P computations or NP okay but
the scaled down version not expert or
next even though you can but it's it'll
be kind of this is the regime that kind
of were interested in even though it
expands the higher complexity classes
you should think of tears n to the 10
and to the hundred yeah exactly where n
is the input length actually both of
them are gonna be poly log and actually
I want to say I'm hiding something this
is a remark more to the expert experts
in the audience but usually there's also
a security parameter that comes into the
picture I'm kind of hiding it you can
think of log T poly log T as being the
security parameter I'm kind of omitting
it from the slide for a simplicity yes
thanks Rex will happen in people
yes oh okay this I'm not thinking of
this as a message the message is just
the proof of the computation yeah so
yeah the parameters are short and the
proof length is short if even if like X
is long no just a parameter that you can
that are sent in the beginning of time
okay so okay so what do we want so we
set the thickness but now we of course
want the standard one completeness and
soundness what what do you mean by
completeness of course if if you do the
computation correctly you should prove
that the verify will accept you okay
just standard completeness so for any
computation if you did it correctly
you generate the proof correctly the
verifier will accept you that standard
completeness soundness is a bit more
tricky so first one adaptive soundness
we want to say any cheating prover he
sees the parameters now we can choose
maliciously any any computation of his
choice
if the computation that is not one and
he proves that it's one then he'll be
rejected with various oh he'll be
accepted only with negligible tiny
probability so he cannot cheat however
note we only focus and computationally
bounded cheating provers this is similar
to a millon stop which he also assumed
that the p star cannot break lwe our
pits are also cannot break lwe that's
what we assume our P star cannot break
all the Blooey I want to point out that
in this setting it's kind of inherent
okay we believe that without this
assumption if you allow all-powerful
cheating provers then you cannot do it
there's no way you can do it because of
the IPS equals P space kept your nin
even in the interactive setting and
all-powerful you can only if the
communication is small you cannot only
get bounded at a bounded space
computations so there's no way you can
do all of P or NP if you don't put this
restriction so this restrictions in that
is
necessary in our setting as opposed to
the quantum setting were there for we
don't see any barrier besides not not
knowing how to do it it's actually the
same the same company the assumption I
mean we construct these things under the
lwe assumption learning with error
that's good very good so right so the
question was but I am I said that he can
be large so how can I restrict the proof
of the cheating approver right that's
what you're saying that's exactly why
why I think it's useful for this talk to
think actually of computations in P or
NP but if you want to think of larger
computation that's fine but and so you
can say okay I'm thinking of
computations of size tt can be I don't
know and even two to the N and now I'm
gonna take I'm going to assume that the
cheating prover also runs in time at
most two then and I'm going to take an
encryption scheme that cannot be broken
in time to do then between the security
parameter is much much bigger you can
you can kind of play this game of
amplifying the security department to
deal with larger computations
it's called complexity leveraging in our
world you can do that but I think then
that's why I feel like think of it
actually in the down-to-earth setting of
P n NP is more natural because it's an
hour it's a computationally sound proof
system great that's you guys have great
questions okay any more questions okay
so just say such a scheme if we call it
a succinct non interactive argument so
succeeds because this the proofs are
short not interactive because the proof
itself is not interactive an argument we
call a proof that only computation only
son we call it in cryptography an
argument system okay it's not a proof
you know for sure correct it's an
argument okay so when we call the thing
a snark that kind of the notation that
we use okay so a before we move on I
want to say there's and this may go back
to
his question about reusing the
parameters there are two types of snarks
that were considered in the literature
there's a lot of work on this and
there's two types of snarks one type
that's publicly verifiable meaning
anyone can verify the proof you put the
proof out there anybody given the
parameters and the proof can say oh I
believe the statement is true I read the
theorem I believe the statement is true
the other one is privately verifiable
which means only the person who
generated the parameters can verify so
in order to verify you need some secret
state corresponding to these parameters
in our case it would be like a secret
key corresponding to the public key of
some encryption scheme but without this
secret key you cannot verify the proof
so it's only it's kind of designated
verify only the person who generated the
parameters and has the secret state can
actually verify the proof and I want to
say that our result is in this setting
it's in the private verifiable setting
and you'll see in a second why and let
me say that there's a lot of work in the
publicly verifiable setting and but all
the work we would like our work to be in
the public variable setting it seems
better because I'm verifying the proof
you know you just put it out there
anybody can read it it'll be better to
our knowledge today everything in the
publicly verifiable setting requires
very strong assumptions such as what we
call knowledge assumption or application
type of sub chain they require a very
strong assumption and the focus of this
talk is to get snark under standard
assumption under all the Blooey okay and
in the end of the talk I'll go back to
this point and say how maybe we can get
to the publicly verifiable setting using
our techniques but for now that our
results are in the private verifiable
setting though I do want to mention that
if you allow interaction if you don't
restrict yourself to the non interactive
setting and allow interaction then
already from the 90s we know how to do
this under standard assumptions so the
hard part here is getting this non
interactive solutions yes
doesn't it become publicly verifiable
yes
so what you can do good so the question
about private available was well if no
problem Oh give the secret key and now
it's publicly verifiable you're right
that would be but then first you cannot
reuse it sound non interactive anymore
because every time you need to give so
now but what you difficult key it's not
sound anymore if people see the secret
key the secret state course finds the
parameters sound is breaks so you can
give that secret and everybody can
verify but then you'll need to generate
new parameters for the next proof okay
so the found is relies on the fact that
the secret state course finds that these
parameters are secret if this secret
state is revealed soundness doesn't hold
anymore
okay and going back to all Misha's
question if you can reuse it currently
in our techniques a you can reuse it as
long as you don't learn the secret state
if you learn every time if you're
accepted or rejected accepted or
rejected this information can actually
reveal information about the secret
state in which case it's broken so you
can reuse as long as you're not rejected
too much if you reject it too much
you'll need to give new public
parameters good what's the difference if
you do allow interactions where the
difference between this is the most
yeah so the muggle paper is in the
interactive setting and there we can do
it but the muggle paper so this is a
specific paper that dude is talking
about there it's information theoretic
security even it's not even against we
it's it's a sound against any cheating
prover but it's not all of the because
exactly because I said you can't get all
of P so it's restricted only to bounded
depth
yes any more questions
okay so now okay so let me just state
our result and then we'll go to the fun
part where we connect all this to
quantum okay so what are our results so
the first thing we construct a snack for
any deterministic polynomial time
computation under standard assumption
lwe okay after we assume any any fhe can
work but we have a fishy form lwe we can
even there's other assumptions but
that's good enough for us okay moreover
we show even for NP we can get a snark
but only for bounded depths but bounded
space for so for nun and the theresa
computations a bounded space we can also
get a snark where the communication
complexity the length of the proof
depends on the space so we grow the
length of who grows with the space so
for a space for a nun service
computation that require a little bit of
space we do get it also based on kind of
standard standard assumption stand the
reason we have standards kind of quotes
because we need for this result to rely
and sub books financial hardness above
the Blooey
so we need to amp the hardness of the
lwe okay so the point is we do have
snarks for P we have Starks for NP with
bounded space under kind of standard
assumptions you don't sorry the quantum
resilient is sort of
up there it's an additional you don't
need it but yeah right so yeah the
reason is the reason I said quantum
resilient so we're only in these results
we only delegate classical computations
it's not about quantum at all it's just
all getting classical computations the
assumption it's quite a result who cares
well first of all maybe the cheating
prove our you know we're suing is
powerful maybe it's quantum capability
we don't want him to cheat so if you ask
quantum have ability if he breaks up the
value we're screwed but because it's not
the balloon we assume he doesn't break
it so that's one reason another reason
why I'm stressing it here is because at
the end of the talk I wanna encourage I
want to put a slide encouraging you to
to get this result for quantum
computation in which case so you really
want the assumption to be quantum
resilient but yeah so wonderful
any any more questions okay so here
comes the fun part
Oh before let me just say a few words
about this verifiable computation so I
think actually it's a very exciting time
for this question and I want to say four
to two things hey why do we care about
verifiable computation and B why do we
care about non interactive verifiable
computation so we care because you know
delegation happens in the world okay
there are a cloud system that you know
do computations for us and we do want to
make sure that these things are correct
are being done correctly they're
actually used today you know there's
like Z cash company and others that
actually use these things and you know
these are very important they're non
interactive yes the black in the black
chain contains proofs that that transit
that things have been done correctly and
so on so forth so it's actually used and
I want to say that this is one example
where there was a remark before about
efficiency it's actually one example of
like a huge success story of theoretical
cryptography or theoretical a complexity
theory where actually there you know and
there's a lot of these schemes have been
implemented and pushed to practice and
so I I googled I looked for a few
implementations and this is unbelievable
what I'm gonna show you is all based on
really theoretical results and I'm sure
there's more this is
just so here is a bunch of
implementations all been done and based
on these two systems and some deployed
some just implemented but it's a really
you know important topic that I feel
like it's a big success story I've you
know we're theoretical results have been
actually pushed and used okay so now how
do we get that how do we get these lands
and this is where quantum will help us
or now really quantum but quantum models
I should say quantum inspired models
okay so what is that blueprint what is
the idea so the basic idea was already
proposed by 99 by Bill Maher in Wetzel
and here is their idea it's very simple
and elegant that is the following hey
you know what why don't you take a to
prove ER or multi proven I think of to
take a I might be multi proven
attractive proof and convert it was not
to a single prover non-interactive
argument how just take the two queries
that you would give th prover and
encrypt them stand it encrypted using a
fully homomorphic encryption scheme and
help give the answers he'll do the
computation under the hood you know
using the fully human the capability of
the fully homomorphic encryption scheme
that's the proposal before I go into
more details why they proposing and why
it works or doesn't work let me first
what why why did this to Jack why is
this suggestion so good because it turns
out that MIP
are much easier to construct okay are
more easier they're more powerful so
what do I know about MIP MIP turns out
so first what is an MIP MIP this is
important this the soundness it's a to
prove or multiple interruptive proof and
the sound is really relies on the fact
that the to prove errs or to clouds do
not interact okay they're not allowed to
interact there's a wall between them
they cannot interact and now they they
prove the validity of a statement to
this weak verifier what's nice about
why this over this is a wonderful model
and the reason it's a wonderful well
it's wonderful from any reason actually
was proposed by benefit I'll to get zero
knowledge and for each interval zero
knowledge crypto was kind of the
inspiration but forget about poor crypto
aside it's amazing because it's very
powerful you can you can prove any
computation in nano terrific time T or
the communication complexity it's only
poly log in T it's exactly what we want
okay so time T computations
deterministic or non-deterministic the
the length of the proofs or the
communication is only poly long the
verifier is very efficient even the
provers here are efficient it really
gives you what you want the provers here
running time poly t like the computation
the verifier is very efficient
communication is very efficient exactly
what we're looking for but it requires
two non interactive provers this we
don't want to have we want one prover so
that was exactly their idea their idea
well you know you have everything you
want except for the two non interactive
provers convert it to protocol with one
prover you know you have everything so
now the question is this sound is this
protocol sound
questions before I will go into the
soundness okay
let's see let me first convince you that
it sound okay why why is this sound
look reason for not to be sound is
because now the cheating prove er you
know we can't give him the two words and
if he sees the two queries he can cheat
but he doesn't see them the way you
should think about fully homomorphic
encryption so this is a fully
homomorphic a encryption scheme okay so
after before we go to soundless just
know this we assume it's a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme thanks
that they can be note we know how to
construct this from lwe so the
assumption is lwe like I promised okay
and this is the scheme now why why why
is this scheme sound because how should
you think of these encryption scheme
intuitively you should think about them
as locked boxes right so nobody can say
it's opaque
you have query one the poor cheating
prove all goes into the green box he
can't see anything but he does the
computation that he should to get a 1 he
doesn't think you to when he does that
the automation oq2 he just sees q1 he's
in the Box you know the other box is
opaque with a different color when he
goes to q2 he does the same so it's
definitely what you know so it should be
so the point of what the reason it's
sound because these queries are hidden
they're hidden like they should be and
yet you can still do the computation
which is the you know the the magic of
fully homomorphic encryption you can't
see but you can compute this is
wonderful so this was proposed there was
even some proof of security in some
paper of this heuristic was wonderful we
were all happy until there was a proof
that there wasn't it was notice this
exactly not sound
okay so I don't know if you were
convinced by my argument that didn't
sound but turns out it's not sound and
the reason it's not sound is is delicate
so let's see what went wrong do you want
me to go back well I'm trying
so I'll tell you what went wrong why
don't we know about MIP the sounds of
MIP really relies on the fact that
answer one is only a function of query
one answer to is only a function of
query 2 this is what you guys call local
strategies okay what happens in our
setting well ideally like I said you
know what does the cloud do he took
stick to green box you know does the
computation takes the pink box or purple
box does the computation and that's it
that's what it that's the only thing he
can do however in reality I mean here's
the boxes the boxes are not really
opaque boxes the end of the day they're
bits now I don't know what he can take
the bits encrypting q1 add them to the
bits encrypting q2 a god knows what he
does and it turns out it's not the same
thing moreover and now maybe the quantum
people are going to wake up a bit turns
out he can actually do more than local
strategies what I can do is you know
these spooky strategies and let me
explain to you why okay so okay what
does the encryption scheme actually
promises us so what we did we hit we hit
the queries using an encryption scheme
but what is it that the encryption
scheme really promises us it's not
actually an opaque box like I said it's
a digital thing and the only thing it
promises us is that is what we call
semantic security what is the semantic
security what it says essentially is if
you look at a one it doesn't reveal
information about you to beyond what's
already known about q1 you cannot gain
information by looking at a1 in q1 about
you by look at any one you cannot gain
information about you about q2 sorry
so may repeat I think I said abruptly
looking at a1 if you open the green box
you do not learn any information about
the other query you - that will break
semantic security and similarly if you
open this box a - you will not learn any
information about the other query beyond
what you could already learn from q2
that's that's exactly what encryption
the semantic security offers you which
is exactly non signalling for those of
you who are familiar with this concept I
can also answer questions ok ok Hey any
questions I'm gonna go deeper into this
but before I go deeper any yes ok ok ok
so yes so first time really non
interactive schemes so why are we
looking at these interaction it's
ultimately gonna be one round right
exact so yeah so good so the world let
me just go back here ultimately these
queries are gonna be my public
parameters they're gonna be fixed I had
I mean they're gonna be fixed they're
gonna be reused all the time and then
whenever you want to give whenever a
computation comes along and you want to
prove to me that a man x equals 1 after
tea time steps then you're you're gonna
think of these are the queries that your
MIP and you're gonna give me these
answers so it this is just that the
proof is just this message I but you
have a very good point because I am
using the fact that an ident stated
explicitly that the mi piece that I'm
you that our MIP
has the property that the queries do not
depend on the statement so the these
queries they don't depend understatement
why can't like in the prover just commit
to the entire proof or say take a hash
tree of the proof and
okay so right so the prover can take the
entire proof commit but then he needs to
open it how when you okay used you took
the entire long proof you committed to
it good but now what I I'm not I just
saw commitment as a verifier well so
actually what your intuition is very
very good because the Killian protocol
that I mentioned the interactive one is
exactly of this form what he does in the
Killian protocol he takes a PCP
producing shadow proof and he tree
commits to it and then in the next round
he sands queries and then the verb so
it's a formal kind of you send the hash
you get a commitment you ask reveal and
you reveal exactly that's the entire
thing is how you make this protocol non
interactive yes wonderful thanks for
asking okay okay so as I said I said the
encryption what it promises you is that
you doesn't promise locality it only
promises that the cheating approver must
behave in an unsettling way that's all
it is actually it's worse it's almost
time signaling but it's even worse and
the reason it's even worse because it's
not true
that I said a one doesn't reveal Q 2 and
a 2 does reveal Q 1 but it's not really
it's only two polynomial time machine
actually Q 2 sorry a one can be the
encryption of Q 2 so of course it
reveals Q 2 you can take the encryption
and a two could be the encryption of Q 1
similarly right so the only thing
encryption promises you is that in the
eyes of a polynomial time machine or
that I have someone who cannot break the
encryption only in his eyes
q 2 doesn't reveal information about
anyone ok
so let me explain how this so actually
what we need is not classical in my
piece that's not good enough for us
because classical on rps are only good
against local strategies what we need
to start is with a non signet with an
MIP that secured its non signaling
strategies and actually even more than
that
we need them IP to be secured against an
adversary that actually signals but it
signals in a way that a polynomial-time
person cannot cannot see that he signals
in this is what we call computational no
signaling so a strategy that looks nose
look like it's no signaling but it can
it can actually signal information
theoretically and we need to be secure
against these kind of things okay so
okay so I'll skip through this fast
because I'm not I don't have much time
and because the formalism I think is not
that important but you know there's a
non signal I call 99 m IP it's just a
shortcut for saying m AP that secure
against non signaling strategies a so
non signaling strategies just says write
that answer one is independent of Q to
conditioned on Q one loses speaking of a
a one hides Q 2 hides meaning it doesn't
contain any information that's when an
signaling and similarly similarly for a
two hides Q 1 what we need is
computational non signaling or more
generally T non signaling which means
that a one hides Q 2 or 8 y q are only
from a polity machine and the reason I
put in here T teachers to think of poly
ideally our Observatory what we showed
and this is the connection to the non
signaling we showed if you can come up
with an MIP that is secure against non
signaling strategies or teen on signal
for any T if there's this empty poly or
more than poly and you can come up with
a proof that secure even if a cheating
approver not only is non signalling it's
even signaling but in a way that I teach
polity time adversary can I detect that
it's signaling if you have such a thing
then you're sound then you have then
this is good you have your snark this is
the snark that's it
and so the only goal is to construct
these MIP one that's secure ideally
against poly non-settling strategies and
then you're secure against assuming part
the fhe is phenomenally secure okay so I
do I'll just say we constructed it 4p
exactly as we wanted it
what about NP we didn't do it for all of
NP we did it for bounded space NP I
don't go into the details just want to
mention it's impossible for all of NP
okay because we know that in general non
single ami P is equal to experts not
more than X so the scaled down version
here is gonna be in like n to the power
log in a or not all of em P a so let me
summarize and end with a very I want to
summarize to get to my open problem that
I think is interesting so what we showed
the point that I want to want to
emphasize we have even though we're
trying to do a snark that has nothing to
do with quantum we just want to you know
delegate verify delegate classical
computations that's it we just want non
interactive solutions the way we got to
there is via constructing an MIP that
secure against non filling strategies
I'm not gonna say anything about how I
construct these MIP that's pretty
technical requires a big talk no I'm not
gonna say anything about how these are
constructed a but I can say it's
actually we use kind of the BF Ellis and
we almost died we changed it very little
in all the hard part is in the analysis
so yeah so the question was can you use
this for quantum computations or you can
use it yes and I'm gonna next slide I'm
gonna talk exactly I think about what
you're saying yes you can you can and
we're gonna get to that in a second
exactly how a and then an okay we
constructed you know a these non
signaling the things for P and for some
classes of NP which I don't want to talk
about but then it immediately gives you
the sounds that you want okay so the all
the hard part was actually you know the
constructing there's no signaling things
which I won't talk about right good yeah
right so good so what what Tomas was
saying is right is actually we construct
this non signaling MIP
it's not what to clouds we have poly log
many cards so we have here poly log many
boxes but this theorem is true for any
number of boxes you take any you take
MIP with any number of provers and you
convert it to a snark with the same
number of boxes
because of the limit on the power of MIT
but we know that MIT start which is
where the troopers are life chair okay
that's a very good question
so first I want to say that you have a
great good question first I want to say
uh so what I said is non signaling him
the approach of going from non
signalling ma P to here will not work
for all of NP because non singling MIP
and its own is not a strong enough model
however you can reach here the other
means nobody said that the only way to
go is to go through non sitting here
maybe you can go give another snog
that's possible but but there is
actually a negative result in from the
quantum from the crypto literature by
Gentry nuoc from 2011 I believe where
they showed that actually coming up with
a snark for oven P under standard two
graphic assumptions will require new
techniques it's kind of impossible via
blackbox reductions which is what we're
used to working with so it seemed like
concerning snap-valve NP is beyond our
current capabilities but that's what the
negative result from the crypto
community so you know it doesn't seem
yeah I don't know but but maybe you can
get other results not only for bounded
space via other regimes of not
necessarily non signaling you're right
bqp let's talk about bqp so all what we
showed now yeah there is not no right oh
we show now we talked about about us
about classical computations okay we
delegated classical computation
what about quantum computations let's
still get we're here in the quantum
workshop let quantum computations know
here's the thing
if anyone succeeded bqp if you can come
up with a non signalling MIP for bqp
then we're golden
why well thanks to Oh Mila you know we
have a feature for quantum computations
you really just take the - that's it you
get a snack for completing computations
so if you come up with an unsettling or
computationally non signalling MIP for
quantum computation then you get a snark
automatically I think that's a very very
good problem you know it would be great
if we if you know we can get here so
that's definitely something I would like
I would like to see I would like to work
on or you guys even better you guys work
on a don't the next thing I want to say
which is kind of interesting is I would
like to make these snogs publicly
verifiable after we have a direction of
doing it and I think it's interesting
also related a little bit to non
signalling so why we said this is
privately verifiable why because to
verify the proof you need to decrypt if
you need to decrypt you need you need
the secret key so only the person who
has the secret keys corresponding can
decrypt okay so so you need the secret
Keys verify that so now why not
everybody can verify only the guy who's
holding these secret keys but maybe I
can use another encoding not
semantically secure you know the most
secure thing maybe you can use another
encoding here that hides the queries but
still allows public verifiability and we
have we have such encoding and it's very
interesting to see how so
but what is it now that non signaling is
not really enough because this encoding
doesn't have semantic security another
question kind of what property do you
really need here to get you know what
property need from the MIP which
need to be more than on signaling to get
publicly verifiable snacks from this
okay so me and the last slide my thing
again
I really think you know this is a you
know beautiful love affair between
quantum and crypto especially seeing
kind of the talks today I think the
results that you know came up in the
last year or two
I'm also before but really now it seems
like a has Ryan a Donald called it
quantum awesomeness a but really I think
it's it's a great time this is I'm very
happy that you guys organized you know
especially this day which seemed to kind
of combine these two communities
together and I really hope to see more
more communication between us going on
moving forward okay thank you
[Applause]
this might be a side question today from
one of the things that we got used to
distinguishing in the selling with one
an interactive system I really talked
about it and then we talked about
blindness sometimes - meaning that the
server doesn't learn to write something
and that's usually not doesn't show up
in these things and confuse it just
because it's infallible because you
could just do the whole thing one extra
layer
exactly so the reason when we talk about
where Phi ability we usually don't
emphasize blindness is because by just
fhu everything like this is immediately
blind right you don't learn anything
because every oh the M right eye but I
can give you an X and T under the hood I
can I get everything in the encryption
so because we have a morphic encryption
we can blind everything by just apply a
genial you're gonna be blind so that's
why we kind of separate the two issues
yeah we get blinded for free yes exactly
thank you in the honest case they're
local they're really local I can allow
that yeah I can allow them but but I'm
saying in our protocols and our actual
protocols for classical computations the
honest people are local but they need it
to be secure even if they were quantum
and even if they were non signalling
perhaps
actually if I do I mean if you're saying
it may be if the honest people if the
honest provers could be non signaling to
or could be quantum they can have more
power that so I think maybe you can do
bqp why not if you know we can if they
share entanglement now they can do more
and that's why you know yeah I think
that's that's exactly the question I
would like to see you know a I think
that's a very that's yeah yeah but bpp
it's trivial because the verify can send
the randomness that you I mean you can
yeah you can yeah you can just send the
randoms ahead of time say that which
randomness you want and know cuz you can
use a PRG absolute right um generator in
crypto there's all this magic that you
can use to make things short and yeah
[Applause]
next up is top